the next category ashley best drip
even goku doesn't look as good i doubt
that
no one looks as good as drip goku yeah
what are the nominees
what the [ __ ] is that so we got ghance
steve [ __ ]
turtleneck of course of course we got a
ladybird's outfit
uh i got my top hat that's not even drip
that's just like a piece of clothing
this trip my berserk shirt which is very
really i don't even remember that
episode
i think that that was because uh we
mentioned it yeah on the live stream
yeah and then connor's uh t-shirt that
you see him wear like five times
the emiya show one of one of the memes
that didn't get shown here which is
connor and like shiro emiya yeah which
he wouldn't get because he doesn't watch
faye anyway
i've seen fate stay right
you know what i mean if there's anything
i don't want to win it's my top hat
because that's not drip
that's literally just a hat i really
want the turtleneck to win i want the
turtleneck
i love how it's steve handjob's
turtleneck it's not gone it's not my
turtleneck
it's just the steve jobs it's the steve
[ __ ] turtleneck yeah well
you would think if steve hendricks won
the nickname category there might be a
bit of
yeah right a bit of uh leaning towards
this i have a feeling
yeah um so let's find out here's one
find out let's find this
category this trip goes to
steve [ __ ]
whoa 50 percent oh my god what's going
on
i'm sad i'm not gonna be able to wear
turtlenecks till winter rolls around
again oh yeah
yeah [ __ ] pointing right now and
second place second place was ladybird
with 23.3
oh that is a gigantic